the first trailer for Marvel's and Madam
the wasp is here and while it might
contain exactly zero hints about what's
to come in the MCU movies are preceded
namely Black Panther and The Avengers
infinity war there are plenty of clues
about what lies ahead for its title
characters in the second ant-man movie
so well are you magnifying glasses and
search along with us as we break down
some of the smallest details to be found
in the first trailer for ant-man and the
wasp anew Anthony one of the saddest
moments in ant-man was certainly the
loss of Anthony Scott Lang's trusty
winged ant pal who carried him through
trials large and small the creature was
well-trained quirky and had a knack for
arriving right in the nick of time
however with hope Van Dyne s new wasp
suit equipped with its own set of wings
Scott's gonna need some aerial
transportation for the new flick himself
so taking you didn't have their tech
available for me not again so as we see
in the trailer he'll have to let his
memory of Anthony go and make a new pal
from the former city family to buzz
around town with frankly Anthony 2.0
could be from the originals own colony
for how much they look alike and what's
even better is it looks like Lang's new
ride can keep pace with the wasp ax - he
is ghost we don't know for sure whether
ghost portrayed by Hannah John Comyn
will be the biggest bad of ant-man and
the wasp but we do know that the
mysterious character will be coming
along to spook our insectoid heroes a
bit the trailer offers not one but two
glimpses of the villainous in action in
the first sight thing we see ghosts hand
radiating with trippy energy from that
white stealth suit in the second shot of
the character we see ghosts in a full
slate gray costume concealing any trace
of her humanity and leaving us instead
with the red eyed antagonist behold
Goliath another first glimpse of a new
MCU character featured in that man and
the wasp trailer is that of Phil Foster
aka Goliath aka comics second giant man
played by Laurence Fishburne in what
looks like Hank Pimm's lab it's not
clear whether Foster will be in his pre
or post Goliath glory days by the time
he arrives in the ant-man sequel but
Fishburne has hinted that he'll be both
a hero and scientists in the movie
whether that means he's retired his
super suit or not remains to be seen
supersize me it looks like giant man
will be making a comeback in ant-man and
the wasp as well Scott Lang usually uses
his powers to shrink down to a fun size
superhero but in Captain America Civil
War he tried his hand at blowing up to
fight all caps frenemies and man might
have needed some fresh fruit after it
was all said and done to recover from
the experience but for the most part he
handled himself just fine
from the looks of this trailer he'll be
giving Bay Area folks quite a surprise
when he emerges from the water in hyper
size for some reason maybe his suit
regulator gets out of whack again but
Hank Pym should probably develop a
memory eraser device next because this
is one site San Franciscans are not
likely to forget I do some dumb things
missing in action
two of the most intriguing cast
additions for ant-man and the wasp a
Michelle Pfeiffer is Janet Van Dyne aka
the original wasp and Walton Goggins a
sunny birch a smarmy weapons developer
it's expected that thanks to Scott
Lang's prior visit to the quantum realm
Hank Pym is going to order up a mission
to get the original wasp back from said
plane of micro existence however long
that might take the trailer portrays
none of that plotline however and it
also tells us nothing about what to
expect from birch in the comics he's a
relatively small character who gets into
a tiff of Tony Stark's company but since
Iron Man isn't expected to have anything
to do with this movie the running
theories that he'll be taking over for
the late Darren cross aka Yellow Jacket
over at cross technologies will have to
wait for the film or at least a more
revealing trailer to find out more about
either of these theory threads but
clearly Marvel's keeping both of these
exciting characters debuts close to the
chest for now the microscopic realm
Howard cites or heroes might not make
way to the quantum realm just yet in the
film's trailer but it does look like at
least someone will be shrinking down to
the microscopic plane in one snapshot
from the trailer the team's rocket
submarine can be seen drifting through a
cloud of tardigrades of all things
since the micro animals are known to be
water-dwelling creatures we can surmise
a Hank and Co are going to be traveling
somewhere wet before getting to an even
tinier realm
any excuse to show adorable water bears
right thanks for watching click the loop
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you're loved too
you